[Music]
alright guys so I recently sent my dog's
DNA to a dog DNA science place where
they figured out what DNA my dog has and
I wanted to see how legit this dog DNA
place was so what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
swab my DNA I'm gonna send it to the dog
center and I'm gonna see if I have dog
DNA I'm getting like half poodle with
this hair let's see if I'm a dog
[Music]
all right so what I need to do now I
need to swap my mouth and then send away
my DNA my DNA on there so in a couple
weeks or months
I'll know if I'm a duck so I just
realized before I send the package I
have to create a little dog profile for
myself so if they know what dog they're
getting DNA from so what do you call
your dog cutie booty cutie buddy honey
spell booty with a teen identity right
cutie booty okay you're gonna think it's
so weird that their destiny cuz now
whenever I get the DNA back all the
emails are gonna die cutie booties DNA
is now updated so it's cute booty male
or female this cutie booty male tell us
something fun or unique about cutie
bleep a lot of people think cutie booty
is different but cutie booty doesn't
care because cutie booty is huge booty
so I still have a couple characters left
I only used 110 out of 500 so I'm going
to write one more sentence human booty
is so
[Music]
cute it's cutie blue you already
neutered or expect it to be neutered
this Judy booty not neutered right I'm
not neutered that's it
profiles may cutie booty let's do this
baby let's figure out what kind of dog I
am alright so it has been a month and I
just got an email the DNA results are in
I'm about to open up the email and see
what kind of dog I am this is all I've
been thinking about this whole time I
haven't been able to focus on anything
except for the fact that I might be half
dog or 10% poodle or 5% Labrador we're
72% husky or a hundred percent a
caboodle or 4% Yorkie or less 8.5% I
could get any of those things and I'm
gonna figure that out right now damn it
damn it fine DNA tests are a real thing
they're accurate dog DNA tests aren't a
scam it said the saliva wasn't able to
be processed something went wrong what
went wrong is that I gave him human DNA
damn it I guess what I should do is do
some research and give you some sort of
information as to why the results came
out the way they did and why this video
turned out pretty boring and I'm not a
dog
so let me see
yeah I couldn't figure out how the DNA
stuff works I spend a couple hours
researching I have no idea so what I'm
gonna do is actually I'm gonna call
someone from the company to get specific
answers as to how the process works
thanks so much for jumping on this call
I just just got the results back and it
said that I have zero dog in me that
they actually couldn't analyze my DNA so
I was wondering if you could talk a
little bit about how the DNA is tested
and why my DNA didn't match up with any
dogs so the DNA tested with what we call
a microarray so it's this chip and we
put DNA on the chip and we put dog DNA
on the chin yeah the thing about DNA is
that it's a double strand says you have
one strand if you get a matching strand
it sticks together so if you put dog DNA
on our dog chip it's gonna match what
we've put on it and it's gonna tell us
what version of different alleles across
the genome your dog has if you look
human DNA on it it's not gonna match
anything on the chip it just washes
right through and then we're like oh we
didn't get any dog DNA your tests fail
humans have no the DNA is just
completely different than dog DNA pretty
much so if you look at you know the
genes that are coded in the human genome
versus the dog genome they're about 90%
the same of course if you look at the
individual letters making up the genomes
they're only gonna be about 70% the same
and when we're designing our probes
we're looking at dozens and dozens of
letters in a row so even though some of
them are the same in fact most of them
are the same there's enough differences
it just doesn't match up do you think
they're in any there's any plausible
chance that a human DNA would ever just
accidentally stick or match like or is
it a pretty foolproof system it's a
pretty foolproof system so there's
200,000 plus markers on our array it's
it's possible maybe it's the highly
conserved region you get 10 or 20 of
them that do match up with a with the
human and a human test would make a
result there we're still gonna fail that
sample right we want our samples to be
to have over 99% of the chip or training
results we're not going to we're not
gonna
pass a sample that only has 1% or less
returning results mm-hmm that makes
sense
amazing well thank you for clarifying
with me that I'm not at a dog I guess
I'm fully human of a hundred percent
human so thank you for confirming that
and for didn't confirm that you're human
we just confirmed you're not dog
[Music]